[Music]  it's the  beyond beautiful it looks like a piece  of architecture from  from rome something from the medieval  ages and  i'm just impressed just to say the least  very impressed  [Music]  yes we started with the corona on top  and  we give it a crown because corona means  ground it's like nice and double  but we give it also crime because it's  ruling it's ruling our lives everywhere  it tells you what to do it tells you to  wear a mouth  protection it tells you to you know to  stay away from your family and  not go to the the nice places don't do  the activities  stay home  [Music]  [Applause]  they have to reach the top to inject the  corona  to kill it and then when it's killed we  can go back and do all the activities  [Music]  again  you